calling someone a fat disgusting return
no truth I'll give it to you [ __ ]
for me that's indicative of just a black
filthy soul first question of the day
when as it relates to the the
Schneiderman issue I mean do you really
think that no one knew about this kind
of a scandal this guy was a darling of
the New York leftist elite his abuses
are almost too numerous to count is it
possible is it possible your honor that
we never heard about it before this
league for the same reason the front
page CNN article covering this story
today didn't showcase any of the facts
that I'm about to fill you in on Eric
Schneiderman when he resigned over the
sexual assault allegations the big thing
is Nidoran was a big vocal proponent of
the hashtag me too movement and he was
bring it he's a freak a little bit of
yeah he brought legal action against
Harvey Weinstein in the state of New
York maybe I said maybe we just thought
the me to campaign was just a boys club
for men you also like to yes and really
[ __ ] tonight a man is he since
apologized by the way so he's on the
apology tour you blaming circumstances
like his alcoholism of fatherless
upbringing but mostly [ __ ] who don't
know when to shut up he think that's the
biggest reason why this got out Wow
so here's some quotes from the original
article by the way that you won't find
the CNN piece so ah surprise selves
Aerith nom
I hope I'm spelling it right with who's
born in Sri Lanka has dark skin and she
recalls that he started calling me his
quote brown slate and demanding that I
repeat that I was his property okay this
was not okay we have extreme abuse we
have violence we have racism we have
sexism with hashtag me too it'll be
covered for about a day and a half
before we move back to Trump Russia
exactly and by the way this guy cocktail
chaos yes and he cleared me was innocent
until the recent it took the leaked
footage surfacing recently
[Music]
all right so pretty date is pretty
damning yeah yeah so he talked in the
article he talks about how he slaps
women and how they usually like it so a
direct quote
you'd be surprised he claimed a lot of
women like it they don't always think
that they like it but then they do and
they ask for more well here's here's a
little he said she said she said quote
the slap started after we gotten to know
each other it was at first as if he were
testing me then it got stronger and
harder and she said it wasn't consensual
this wasn't sexual play-acting this was
abusive demeaning threatening behavior
nighttime in was violent he often made
sexual demands she says he was obsessed
with having a threesome and said it was
my job to find a woman by the way
warning three below there if you have
kids in tonight's show we have to be
honest with the thing that you're not
reading sometimes he'd tell me to call a
master and he'd slap me until I did it
was my job to find a woman he made these
women go out and find him other women
this goes beyond role-playing he was
actually forcing them to perform unpaid
labor he made them actual slaves he was
they were a slave headhunting agency
these dudes come out in a tweet and
basically said look this was all during
sex this was just a role play acting
right they wanted me to slap him around
a little bit till 8:00 till I said her
defense skill I sent her to the
piggly-wiggly to retrieve my growth as
well another sex slave he also took
sedatives he pushed this girl to drink
and he said to her drink your bourbon
turnip which was his nickname for and I
didn't know until sin computer told me
what turnip is apparently maybe if it
means sweet odds yes what Turk like
urban dictionary urban dictionary for
[ __ ] really yeah now in his drunken
stupor he confused his root vegetables
with his tubers so that's what here's
the thing I always feel a little bit bad
writing I'm talking about we're we're
when people get divorced and then
information comes out of like sexual
preference is it something to happen
with a woman of the guy I can't make
heads or tails of the drink your bourbon
turn it drink this alcohol you [ __ ]
can you can you can you perform this
this absolutely Dib
this debasing sexual favor like you have
down syndrom can just the role-playing
we're gonna do this isn't Princess Leia
don't you love it it's just terrible
this is absolutely terrible after the
former governor it says end of the
relationship you told several friends
about the abuse and number of them
adviser to keep the story to herself
arguing that Schneiderman was too
valuable as a politician she warned her
that politics was tough and a personal
business and that she'd better be
careful this is the NCR the Corleone
family yes exactly and you know it's
just again how do you think nobody knew
about this no husband no brother no
father wanted to kick a guy's ass when
he forced fed them bourbon calling them
a turnip
hashtag me too but we're okay with the
actual rape culture as long you check
the right boxes this is I didn't spend a
computer found this so this is very
recent as well let alone since minors
will get into Samantha be pat him on or
show now one might say it was bordering
on glowing we have that power now and
with great power comes great
responsibility
oh my god
[Music]
you are fighting the good fight many
fights with women apparently yeah I'm
fighting turnips it's like Super Mario 2
just put him back in the ground and I
slapped him and I make him drink bourbon
this is my house of cards started to
really suck because it could not keep up
with reality no it could not it just
comes on watching television when they
try to I'll do it again they were they
were carrying his water right Samantha B
and then just recently he put up a tweet
referencing her and you have the overlay
Sven computer and then she said take
this to F down what shows us and she
also took the screen it was shows that
she has no she has no comprehension of
how Twitter and/or social media works
nor copyright violations apparently this
down by the way you can't delete my
screen take this down even though he
distributed it freely and publicly hi
you know this is the thing I was talking
about this a friend's dad I remember
when I was a kid he I totally this story
when I set out
he asked for a woman for directions I
was 12 I said ah we're gonna get lost
and he said that sexism and I don't
tolerate that in my car Steven of a
Canadian guy but you know his son was
actually stealing drugs from his drawers
that he was stealing from the hospital
so that was the out where the outrages
over the sexist joke which was funny for
a twelve-year-old mind you yeah this is
what it's allowable from the left as
long as you check the right boxes it's
not about letter of the law it's not
about spirit of the law it's about let
it go they're legal it's only they don't
even sure you're bringing your own laws
they have no idea what their own rules
are it's checked the right boxes jimmy
kimmel all right we know you're a
dirtbag we know you're probably gonna be
next in this list there's gonna be a
story coming out after hashtag me too
but we're gonna give you a pass right
now because you cried about health cares
all right Weinstein we know what's going
on but you get a lot of money to the
right car there we're gonna check that
box
all right Schneiderman all right Schumer
but you know what okay we're gonna check
you checked the box so we're gonna give
you a pass and I don't want to do the
comparison game okay remember I got I
was obviously upset with the grab by the
puck to your mark because I think that
was indicative of a dirtbag who might
abuse his power with a woman and if
that's my wife when he was talking about
other people's watch I would be mad so I
had to be consistent but again not can
we understand where I'm coming from now
that being said what we're talking about
checking boxes that you know when you're
favors you could do it every you grabbed
by the [ __ ] okay that is indicative of
a fantasy that young boys to one very
degree or another had at some point in
their lives in the sense that it's not
unnatural for a boy to imagine throngs
of naked women throwing themselves at
him to the point that he could have his
pick I'm not saying that it's right but
I'm saying okay that's a perversion of
the natural dirt daddy yes but not
abnormal versus calling someone a fat
disgusting return no truth I'll give it
to you [ __ ] that's indicative of
just a black filthy soul it is a
horrible soul from the inside out
today's Democratic Party usually this is
the point where I would tell you to
subscribe or hit the notification bell
up there because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot on YouTube but if
you've been signed up now at ladder with
credit com / mug club for all the daily
content to support us there's probably
there's not a pitch I can make here
that'll work so let me just tell you
this I have a cat in my basement right
now if you don't subscribe it louder
with CARICOM / mug club to support this
content I am going to kill him if you
don't subscribe this cat in my basement
will die